hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll those of you
who have been regular listeners are of
course experts on what we call string
theory the physicists way of thinking
about some physicists anyway way of
thinking about replacing point particles
and particle physics with little loops
of string string theory purports to be a
theory of everything including quantum
gravity and all the other forces of
nature and in a previous episode with
Clifford Johnson we explored the basic
ideas of string theory and why
physicists like it so much there are of
course problems in string theory
especially with connecting it to
observations one of these problems is
that string theory naturally lives in a
10 dimensional space-time and you can
get rid of the extra six dimensions to
make string theory look more like our
four-dimensional world but there's more
than one way to do that the collection
of all the ways of compacta fiying these
extra dimensions is called the string
theory landscape and every single
compactification might lead to different
apparent laws of physics in our
observable world now scientists are very
good at being given lemons and turning
them into lemonade so strengths ears
theorists have said well maybe they're
all real maybe this landscape of
different possible ways to get down from
ten dimensions to four dimensions all
take place somewhere out there in some
large cosmological multiverse maybe this
is a good thing
the story goes long to say because maybe
certain things that are surprising about
our observed world becomes less
surprising if our world is just one of
many universes in this large ensemble
now not everyone agrees this is
controversial stuff but before we can
have a pinyon about it one way or the
other we have to understand what's going
on
today's guest Brian Greene has done very
influential work on string theory in
general but especially on the problem of
compact defying those extra dimensions
in the many ways that we think we can do
it and exploring their cosmological
implications you might know Brian better
as a best-selling author his books
include the elegant universe and the
fabric of the cosmos among others he's
also been the host of specials on nova
on PBS that explains on these
tarek ideas and he's also the co-founder
of the World Science Festival so I think
it's safe to say that Brian green is one
of the most effective and respected
popularizers of science especially of
high-level theoretical physics that we
have in the world today Brian really has
a true gift for explaining very
difficult concepts and that's what we
have in front of us
in the mindscape philosophy I'm not
going to tell you what's right or wrong
we're gonna give you the ideas and you
can decide for yourself
let me give my occasional note that we
love it when people pledge to the
mindscape on patreon or PayPal you can
see the links on the web page and of
course leading leaving nice reviews on
iTunes and elsewhere is always a good
thing so this is going to be both a fun
and enlightening episode I hope you
enjoy it let's go
[Music]
Brian Greene welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you good to be here this
is a special event for a few reasons for
one thing it's the first live show that
we're doing like the landscape podcast
it's not technically supposed to be a
live show but we're sitting here in
Columbia University in Brian's office
and several of his students are hanging
around listening to what we have to say
so oh maybe I'll be laughter jokes you
know applause that's what we're shooting
for guys all right so we actually I
actually did an interview with Clifford
Johnson fairly recently where we did the
history and motivation of string theory
so I'm going to proceed under the
assumption that all the listeners here
have absorbed all of that and they know
what string theory is but just to be
safe why don't we give the basic story
of the particular feature of extra
dimensions in string theory and what
we're supposed to do about them yeah
sure so again not to cover ground that
you already covered with Clifford but
the basic idea is that Einstein had this
dream of a unified theory that would put
our understanding of everything in some
sense together into a single theoretical
framework and he died without finding
that unified theory but then in the late
60s and 70s this idea of string theory
came along which suggested a possible
way of putting all of nature's forces to
get there in a quantum mechanical
framework which is actually even beyond
what Einstein actually had in mind
and when people studied the equations of
the theory they found somewhat
surprisingly that the math only was
internally consistent if the universe
had more than three dimensions of space
and depending on exactly when you look
at the theory in the timeline of
unfolding the exact number of dimensions
that the math required has changed for
reasons that we completely understand
it's not as other someone throwing a sum
dice around to figure out what the
number of dimensions is but the question
that you ask is what in the world do you
do with the theory that says that there
are more than three dimensions of space
people of weaker constitutions would say
well there are three dimensions of space
string theory predicts there are
9 or whatever therefore the theory is
wrong they may not only have weaker
Constitution they may be much smarter
than than generations of physicists who
perhaps have been wasting their time on
the possibility that there really are
these extra dimensions but the reason
why we're not willing to so quickly
discard these theories that suggest that
their other dimensions is that a we
believe that there are ways to make
sense of them that is to make them
compatible with all known observations
and be the mathematics that yields this
possibility of more than three
dimensions achieve some at least on
paper spectacular things so with the
payoff being huge namely the possibility
of a unified theory of gravity and
quantum mechanics any other forces of
nature and with the possibility that the
extra dimensions could actually be real
and around us right at this very moment
we're willing to entertain that
possibility can I just ask maybe this is
not a fair question but what is the
percentage chance you would put on
string theory being a correct
description of nature physics by
probability yes a very quantum
inherently I'm not basing the adriaen I
here yeah you know um it's a somewhat
unfair question because I don't feel at
the moment that we have enough to go on
we've had the possibility a longshot
possibility of finding extra dimensions
say at the Large Hadron Collider and
nothing turned up but we knew that that
was the most likely outcome by virtue of
the fact that the extra dimensions are
likely to be so small that the energies
required to access them is so high that
the Large Hadron Collider simply
wouldn't have enough power to do so so I
would I would say 50/50 would be the gut
reaction on whether or not these these
theories are relevant to the world and
if you ask me a slightly different
question which is what how how strongly
do I feel about the beauty of the world
if there are extra dimensions I think
it's spectacular I mean what a wonderful
idea
yeah that the way you unify the laws of
physics is by stepping beyond the
dimensions that we know about allowing
for a new perspective so to speak the
analogy that people sometimes use is you
know if you if you look at planet Earth
with all of the complexity of the
geography and the topography if you're
walking around it looks like it's a
haphazard collection of things but yet
if you pull out you see this beautiful
spherical earth floating in the black
void and how beautiful is that unified
theory of Earth that only becomes
apparent when you go off into another
dimension that is the dimension of
altitude of height so in the same way if
we go beyond the three dimensions that
we know about a space and have these
other dimensions and all of a sudden it
all clicks together into a unified
theory back to deeply satisfying you're
just asking the Flat Earth contingent to
flood my youtube comment but even though
physicists don't like to attach
probabilities to their theories you do
vote with your feet right you decide
what do you think is most worth working
on and you is it fair to call yourself a
string theorist at this stage of your
yeah I would say so it's certainly been
a dominant theme in the work that I've
done but at the same time I would say
this sometimes I'm described you know
because I mean you've written books too
so you know how you can get pigeonholed
by virtue of the things that you do in
that domain I've sometimes been
described as a proponent of string
theory and I don't consider myself a
proponent of strength here I consider
myself someone is excited about the
possibility that string theory is the
right description of the world but I
reserve judgment to ultimately base my
assessment on observation and experiment
or and and so from that perspective if
tomorrow someone came along with
evidence that showed us that string
theory is wrong maybe some mathematical
inconsistencies of the theory or some
quality of the world that was
fundamentally impossible to incorporate
within the theory could prove that
mathematically for instance I would
happily and I don't I don't mean this in
some pejorative way or even some
dismissive way
or a sarcastic way I would truly happily
move on because I'd like to consider
myself as you and everybody else I
suspect would say we're all after truth
and I don't care what flavor truth is I
just don't want to be wasting my time
and something that's demonstrably not
true and if string theory falls into
that category I'd let it go like a hot
potato but so far it hasn't and in part
because we have clever ways to hide the
extra dimensions from our views so what
are those some of those clever ways well
they're two dominant ways the one that
was studied most intensively even going
way back long before string theory to
the early decades of the 20th century is
that the world could have two kinds of
dimensions big and obvious dimensions
that are easy to see with the naked eye
and those are the ones that we obviously
know about left-right back-forth up-down
but there could be other dimensions of
space that are tightly curled up
crumpled up into a very small shape so
small as the theory goes that we can't
detect such shapes with the naked eye or
even with today's most powerful
equipment so that's one way they're all
around us they're just too small for us
to see and too small for today's
technology to even access the other
possibility is that the dimensions in
principle could actually be quite big
but we're unable to probe into those
extra dimensions because of the way that
we access the world so we see things
with our eyes which are sensitive to
photons imagine the photons can't
penetrate into those extra dimensions
even though they're big and even though
they're all around us photons absolutely
are unable to penetrate then again we
won't see those extra dimensions because
of that probe being unable to go into
that additional spatial part of the
world that is there but we're unable to
access and how big could they these
dimensions be well because gravity is a
force that's highly sensitive to the
geometry of space and time and almost
all these theories gravity can penetrate
in some way shape or form into these
extra dimensions and that places a
constraint on how big those dimensions
can be so in conventional approaches
maybe the dimensions might be oh you
know a millionth of a millimeter across
or something of that sort
so that still sounds small but it's
actually enormous it's small yeah but
it's actually enormous yeah to the
Planck scale which is say you know 10 to
the minus 33 nanometers so that's the
typical size when we look at the
equations of string theory the Planck
scale as the size of the extra
dimensions but there's a great deal of
flexibility that comes with this other
way of hiding them from common view yeah
and so one of the things that I say
sometimes I tell a story and a
historical story and correct me if this
is wrong but in 1998 we discovered that
the universe is accelerating and the
simplest explanation we have for that is
that there is energy in empty space
itself right that there is vacuum energy
or Einsteins cosmological constant and
that story I tell is that this empirical
database finding changed the course of
string theory is that fair assessment I
think it's a fair assessment
initially when that discovery was made
there was a concern that it might
actually rural string theory out because
the energy that you're referring to had
great people had great difficulty
incorporating it into the models of the
world that were emerging from the
equations of string theory and that
definitely was a strong motivation for
people to try to find some new clever
mathematical way of making the equations
of string theory aligned with the
observations of the accelerated
expansion of the universe and groups of
physicists claimed that they achieved
that goal and the community by and large
agree with them that they had succeeded
in incorporating this dark energy this
accelerated expansion into the
mathematics of string theory as of today
there's grumblings that perhaps that was
accepted to quickly raise D yeah and
that and we're so people are now and
this is a sign of a healthy field
reevaluating the state of the theory
relative to the observations that may
impact it so you're right it did have a
significant influence on the course of
string theory and even today is again
influencing people's thinking for a
second round if you will to try to make
sure that the theory is actually
compatible with the observations
yeah and just in saying that actually I
realize I'm skipping ahead because I'm
too excited about talking about
cosmology and so forth but we need to
get on the table the idea that there's
more than one way to hide the extra
dimensions and those different ways show
up in our visible low-energy world right
yes the the beauty of string theory is
that it's not merely a matter of hiding
away and embarrassing quality that the
theory says that there should be more
than three dimensions of space if it was
merely a matter of hiding it away I
don't think that people would have been
all that excited about this prospect
certainly as a graduate student in the
dark ages you know that will be mumble
years yeah yeah a very long time ago
when I learned that strength II required
extra dimensions and that the precise
shape of those extra dimensions could
impact the low energy physics that we
can observe say at a particle
accelerator I thought that was the most
spectacular collection of ideas that I'd
ever encountered yeah
so my my thesis my dissertation was
among the first calculations to take
specific shapes for the extra dimensions
and extract from them predictions which
you can't see my air quotes with my
fingers here on the on the on the
podcast but to try to see whether we
could extract some predictions for
qualities of the world that we might be
able to observe like the number of
particles that are around us and even in
principle how they interact in their
masses so yes there is in principle a
wonderful link between the way you hide
the extra dimensions and the physics
that you actually observe
I remember the specific thing that I
thought it was always fascinating was to
claim that string theory could explain
why there are three generations of
matter particles of you know there's the
electron the muon the Tau hoo or
that while in fact Columbia is the the
home I Robbie Robbie who wondered who
ordered them you on the other things
like that that people should know about
and it actually could even explain that
how can the shape of the extra
dimensions give us three copies of the
electrons yeah so so the idea is you are
studying the equations of string theory
as they manifest in a world that has
extra dimensions of a very specific
shape and the number of solutions to the
equations dictates the number of
particles that you'd see in the world
around you and while it might be a
little bit hard to picture if you're not
used to solving equations on curve
shapes the precise way that the shape
curves on itself has a direct impact on
the number of solutions of your
equations and it was found that there is
a quality of the shape which
mathematicians had long known about it
has a technical names called the Euler
characteristic or the Euler number but
the details of the name don't really
matter but that quality of the shape
dictates the number of solutions so you
could go to a mathematician in principle
and say hey we're looking for a shape a
six dimensional shape that has such and
such mathematical features and the Euler
number is such that it gives rise to
three generations three collections of
solutions to these equations and that
sent mathematicians scurrying about in
some sense at the service of physicists
which is sort of a curious state of
affairs to come up with these shapes and
shington Yahoo was actually my
postdoctoral advisor came up with a
couple of examples that had the right
order number to agree with the number of
particles that experimenters had long
found so in my dissertation was taking
one of those shapes and then going
further and trying to say okay it gives
us the right number of particles but
does it give the interactions of those
particles does it give the masses of
those particles and those are very
difficult calculations to carry out but
within a certain set of assumptions we
pushed it through and found that didn't
agree with what we saw in the world
around us but that was a sort of a proof
of principle he's saying it's a
falsifiable theory well I wish I was I
wish it was because
in the 1980s when we're doing this there
were only like five known shapes six
known shapes or so for the extra
dimensions and if that were the sum
total of allowed shapes and it perhaps
would be a falsifiable theory you go
shape by shape by shape compared to
observation and if it agreed fantastic
if not you could throw the theory away
and move on the challenges historical
development through the 90s and 2000's
people found more and more candidate
shapes for the extra dimensions it grew
from five to five thousand to ten
thousand and I sort of like to say ten
thousand it's still you know a doable to
analyze the shapes because graduate
students like those who you guys will
one day be neat projects right so there
you go just throw them one shape after
the other seat and then just get it done
but when it then grew from thousands
into millions and billions and depending
precisely on how you count you know a
number that's thrown around that's not
as meaningful as in my town but ten to
the five hundred there's a number that
people throw around and that's just such
a huge number of candidate shapes that
you're never going to analyze them one
by one
yeah and therefore you don't know if it
within there there is the shape that
would agree with all observations and if
it does exist how would you even find it
right so the hope is let's just
summarize where we are so we have this
theory that works really well in ten
dimensions but we've known since the
nineteen teens that you can hide
dimensions by curling them up and if
there were only a few and the way that
you curl them up tells you not only what
particles you have but their masses and
this is why string theory involves so
much math right the geometry and the
topology of the extra dimensions affect
the particles we see and we've been
coming better and better at finding new
shapes and one of the things that gets
affected is the energy of empty space is
that right yeah that's right so it's not
just as you say the masses are the
particles and the number of particles
but in principle all physical qualities
of the world would be encoded in these
shapes for the extra dimensions and and
various ways that we can mathematically
dress them up if you will but you can
still think of it roughly as the shape
so you know it's it's not a bad image
to think of the shape as sort of it's
the DNA of the universe right just like
the DNA sequence within our bodies
encodes the detailed features of how we
appear in the world the precise shape of
the extra dimensions determines the
detailed properties of the universe
itself
yeah and a DNA sequence that is as long
as a human genome there's a huge number
of possible DNA sequences right and this
evolution does not try every one of them
but it lands on one that is pretty good
yes us right maybe we'll get there but
maybe the universe does something like
that but right before we get there okay
so there's this thing called the energy
of empty space in string theory where
there extra dimensions you compactify
them the shape and the size of the extra
dimensions predicts the energy of empty
space but even before we knew about that
there was this thing called the
cosmological constant problem we were
worried about the energy of empty space
even what though we weren't string
theorists so why don't you tell us about
that well the cosmological constant is a
is a wonderfully interesting concept
that's had a twisted history beginning
in 1917 Albert Einstein introduces this
term into his equations of general
relativity in order that he can have a
universe at Statik he had this
philosophical prejudice that the
universe shouldn't be changing at least
in its large-scale structure over time
things in the universe could exist and
change and morph but the universe as a
whole know that always was and always
would be I think that's also what the
observations indicated at the time they
did suggest that that's right so it
wasn't just that if it's that out of his
head you know you look up and it doesn't
say what is happening out there
so the problem though was as others
pointed out to Einstein as well his
equations seemed incompatible with that
view of the universe and Einstein had a
clever way of making it compatible just
changing the equations to include a term
that in some sense would generate a
repulsive gravitational push to
counteract the usual attractive
gravitational pull and in that way yield
the universe that would be steady state
unchanging over time
now when the observations in 1929
revealed the
is expanding Einstein sort of smacked
himself in the forehead and said uh I
wish I hadn't introduced his
cosmological constant and he said away
with it away become famous that's right
for Einstein yeah smart guy almost and
uh so he throws away the cosmological
constant but then you know you
fast-forward to the observations that
you talk about in 1998 when it was
recognized that the universe is not only
expanding but speeding up in its
expansion eat something that's pushing
outward what could that be
cosmology constant there's a natural
possibility that then reappears in the
equations and people are fond of saying
you know even Einsteins bad ideas turn
out to be good you sign up to wait long
enough so there's the cosmological
constant as a as a phenomenological tool
for making our equations agree with what
we observe but the question you ask is a
more theoretical one which is as
particle physicists as quantum field
theories using the tools of the trade
we've had a hard time finding a way
within our mathematics to allow the u-2
to calculate the energy of the universe
and find a sufficiently small number the
natural number for the energy of space
that comes from the wild undulation of
quantum uncertainty playing out in
microscopic domains particles popping
into and out of existence the fabric of
space oscillating in wild ways the
energy that emerges is huge so we have
no trouble getting a cosmological
constant out of our mathematics we have
trouble making it small enough well more
specifically it's a sum of huge things
some of which are positive and some of
which are negative right that's right
and and without very detailed
cancellations between the positive and
negative the order of magnitude of that
number would be about 10 to the 120
where as the number in the relevant unit
to be sort of on the order of one so
we're off by a factor of 10 to the 120
and people are fond of saying that's the
biggest mismatch between a theoretical
calculation and observation in the
history of science so it's a big big
mismatch
I've always felt challenged when I hear
that to come up with a theoretical
calculation that works worst addiction
and yet I could become famous too
so so it's an interesting state of
affairs for now the observations are
saying that it's a nonzero value in
order to explain the accelerated
expansion of space and the challenge for
us is to come up with some theoretical
calculation that yields a number that's
not huge that's small enough to be
compatible with observations and that is
something that people still struggle
with in a mighty way today and there was
this belief before 1998 before we found
the universe was accelerating that the
empirically determined value of the
vacuum energy the cosmos was constant is
clearly really small much smaller than
it should be
therefore it's probably zero yeah it's
much easier to explain the number zero
than a number that's very very close to
zero zero is a is a beautifully
symmetric number and you can imagine as
you sort of were indicating that if
there's some deep symmetry that says aha
there's a positive value contributing to
this number and a negative value and
there's a symmetry that requires that
they be equal in magnitude but opposite
in sign therefore when they combine you
get zero that kind of an argument we
could imagine happening but if the
numbers non zero then what do you do you
know the almost symmetry a partial
symmetry is there a way that even if
there is that kind of a structure that
it won't be upset by further
contributions that might be allowed by
the quantum equations and so without
zero as your anchor you're really
floating off at C and that's where we've
been for a while so we had that is what
we call the cosmos flow constant problem
why is the real vacuum energy so much
smaller than its natural value then once
we found what we think is probably the
cosmological constant in 1998 we were
faced with a new problem in the
coincidence problem right yeah right
because the value is not only nonzero
it's on par with the amount of mass
energy that we observe in the universe
from the molecules and atoms and stars
and galaxies and even including the dark
matter it's all roughly on par so why
would it be the case that this nonzero
amount
of this cosmological constant we often
use the term dark energy because it's
energy that we don't see so it's dark or
invisible why would it happen to have
the value that's so close with the
density of energy from ordinary matter
and energy especially taking into
account the fact that the amount of
energy in ordinary matter the density of
that changes over time as the universe
expands that number gets smaller and
smaller and smaller over time which
means that in principle there could be a
mismatch in the far future between the
amount of energy in this cosmological
constant which may be a number that
doesn't change as it relates to the
amount of matter energy in the stuff of
ordinary existence so why right now
today in this epoch are they close to
each other again it's a problem that
people come up with creative solutions
for but I think it's again a mystery
yeah so just to put people in the
mindset of where we were in 1997 before
we found this we had string theorists
who were you know compacta fiying the
extra dimensions and finding different
ways to make particles and so forth and
apart from a string theory we still had
these general arguments from quantum
mechanics in quantum field theory that
there should be a large cosmological
constant but it is small for some reason
so is it safe to say that most string
theorists took as their task to find a
way to hide the extra dimensions that
left us with zero cosmological constant
at the end of the day yeah I'd say 99%
or more of us had that as the goal the
goal was to not only compactify that is
make the extra dimensions small if it
makes it small in just the right way
that it would agree with the particle
properties of the world and also at the
same time rid us of this cosmological
constant problem by somehow ensuring
that the amount of energy suffusing
space associated with this theory would
be zero because that was what everybody
thought the answer would be and there's
an even more subtle thing that I think
is harder to get across but if you would
you know put a string theorist up
against the wall in 1997 and said okay
the cosmological constant is not zero
is it positive or negative they would
have been much happier with a negative
number than a positive note that's right
that's right there is a clear
distinction in the mathematics between a
positive cosmological constant a
positive amount of this energy and a
negative value for this energy and again
a negative identity might lead some to
wonder what in the world could that mean
and in the theory of gravity energy
really can be positive or negative it
sort of affects the way that space-time
curves so that isn't really a puzzle for
us the positive versus negative side but
certainly the math of string theory was
much happier with a negative or zero
zero value than it was with a positive
value so there may have even been people
in 1997 I would have to check
historically who might have said if we
observe a positive eye for the cosmology
of Contin than this theory can be
discarded there may have been people who
say that I'm not sure I certainly
wouldn't have said it at the time but
there may have been people who felt that
way I do think that there were people
who are at least saying that we have no
idea how to get a positive right dosmo
right constant string theory and then
the universe intervened as it's so often
but actually doesn't do it enough but it
does it in it's very pleasant when the
universe intervenes in a surprising way
right well you know it I'm not even sure
how to judge the development in the
following sense you know is it that
string theorists are very clever
mathematicians such that given a
constraint that does come from the
universe namely the observation of a
positive I of the cosmology Condon they
were able to manipulate the theory in
order to get that answer or is it that
string theory is a very tight logical
structure and it agrees or is able to
agree with the observations because it's
a true description of reality yeah and I
add that that's the key question right
is it the case that string theorists are
just so clever that no matter what you
give them even if it turns out to be
made up they're gonna find some way of
explaining the data or supposed to data
that you provide or is it that it's a
great theory of the world and therefore
the world gives us this quality it's not
surprising that the theory is able to
explain it since I'm not a professional
string theorist I can also add that it's
possible that string theory is correct
and string theorists are very clever at
the same thank you accept that the field
accept it so there we are in 1998 and
the universe rudely tells us that it
seems as if the vacuum energy is
positive we're not even sure about that
there's something pushing the universe
apart the simplest explanation is the
cosmological constant but it could be
something more elaborate so string
theorists slept into action and said all
right we're going to try harder to find
ways of hiding the extra dimensions that
have the property that the vacuum energy
is positive so how did they do well it's
interesting one paper in particular I
think changed most people's mind it's a
paper called usually KKL tea after the
authors who were responsible for this
paper and what they found is that by
throwing everything together that string
theory had in its toolbox the kitchen
said the kitchen sink the proverbial
kitchen sink they were able to combine
those ingredients in just the right way
to give at least a strong argument that
string theory allowed for a positive
amount of this cosmological constant
this positive vacuum energy and with
that paper thousands of others were then
written riffing on this idea developing
this idea trying to see how this idea
might be making paddle with other
observations I mean that's sort of an
endless industry that was spawned by
this this paper and at the same time it
gave us confidence that the theory could
actually agree with observations without
that you know you're in a curious
quandary because if the theory can't
accommodate this observation then either
the theory is wrong or perhaps the
observation itself needs you know
further refinement and maybe at that
version of it the theory would be able
to accommodate but once the possibility
of string theory agreeing with those
observations was
on the table the floodgates were open
and everyone cheered and and and went
forward except not everyone jeered yes
there was the downside that once you can
find a way of compact to find the extra
dimensions that gives you a positive
vacuum energy you can find many yeah a
buttload would be the technical term
right I'm not sure if I've never
encountered that technical term but I
will add it to my vocabulary yes that
that did have an have another effect
which is the one that you're referring
to where people recognized that there
were just so many ways in which the
extra dimensions could be curled up in
principle in a manner that would be
compatible with this positive amount of
the vacuum energy that the old dream
which certainly motivated me when I was
a graduate student I think motivated
many other in the field the old dream
was here is a theory that is going to
give us a unique description of reality
everything that you want to know about
the world will emerge from an
industrious careful analysis of the
mathematical equations and Einsteins
dream is therefore at hand that was the
view in the 1980s the view radically
changed post 1998 and these papers that
were able to show that the positive
mount of dark energy could be explained
with in string theory because now the
view was there are a huge number of
distinct ways of curling up the extra
dimensions that will be compatible the
positive vacuum energy and the best that
we can hope to do is some statistical
analysis on this vast collection this
vast landscape of possibilities and
perhaps the way that we'll describe our
world is by saying hey there are many
many many shapes for the extra
dimensions compatible with all we
observe ours is somehow more likely
there are more of them that agree with
our observations than had the
observations been different and in that
way that we explain our universe not by
a unique description of reality but
rather by a statistical averaging that
suggests that we're run-of-the-mill and
therefore ordinary and therefore the
like the outcome of this unfolding
guided by the equations of string theory
it's a very different way of looking at
reality yeah and even your tone of voice
indicates it's not quite as satisfying
as well yes I mean how beautiful would
it be right to have a unique description
of the world and out of the mathematics
everything that we know emerges and when
you have to go with the combination of
the theory and the observations that's
right and and and what happens is your
aesthetic sense of what's beautiful
changes over time I think it's partly
guided by the way these theories evolve
and there certainly some who have
suggested that this landscape of
possibilities is even more beautiful
because it then eliminates certain class
of questions you can always ask of a
theory why did it turn out exactly that
way right why did it turn out somewhat
different and in string theory the
answered be well actually it did turn
out different it turned out different in
many different universes and we are
simply one of a vast collection of
universes so that question doesn't hold
the same bite as it did when there is
one unique answer and you question why
it turned out that way there are many
possibilities were one of many we're
actually a run-of-the-mill ordinary
expected answer that comes out of this
vast collection and that's all there is
to it it's like an arranged marriage you
get married first love develops later
with this view of the world that's right
you could look at it that way but okay
when you start using words like likely
and evolved and so forth now rather than
the strict string theory problem we
bring in a cosmological problem yes it's
one statement that in the world of
possibilities there's ten to the five
hundred or whatever different ways that
string theory could be compactified
that's the landscape of possibilities
but let's ask about so which one becomes
real or which many become real and
that's when string theorists realized
they needed to think about inflationary
cosmology right that's right because if
you have this collection of universes
allowed by the mathematics you have to
see it yourself is there a mechanism by
which one or many or all of them might
actually be brought into existence and
that's where a union with inflationary
cosmology gives you a natural way
forward because even before string
theorists were talking this
language about many possible universes
the inflationary folks realize that
inflationary cosmology naturally gave
rise to more than one big bang if you
frame it that way
there's this inflationary fuel that
gives rise to a pulse of gravity that
drives everything apart but it's
virtually impossible to use up that fuel
completely right so some of the fuel in
some sense drives our big bang but some
is left over in fact some is created by
the very process and that additional
fuel gives off different BIGBANG's it
varies in far-flung locations in a much
bigger cosmos a much bigger cosmology
combine that idea with string theory and
you say aha maybe inflation doesn't just
yield other universes in the
conventional sense of three dimensions
of space maybe gives rise to other
universes that have these extra
dimensions too and moreover maybe the
different universe is produced by
inflation have different shapes for the
extra dimensions so now in principle
you've got a mechanism that leverages
the insights of inflationary cosmology
the insights of string theory to suggest
an incredibly rich cosmos in which there
are many universes each with a different
shape for the extra dimensions and
therefore each with different
fundamental physics and we live in one
universe with a particular shape for the
extra dimensions not another because
it's the universe in which that shape
gives rise to the properties of the
electron and the quarks and the
chemistry and the biology that allows us
to exist so we are here because the
shape allows us to exist here were not
somewhere else because of the shapes
there aren't incompatible with the
chemistry and biology that allows our
form of life to exist an inflation in
some sense went through that same
aesthetic shift that string theory went
through in the sense that I believe the
original goal of inflation was to say
you know we see features of the universe
it looks more or less the same on very
large scales so I'm going to come up
with a dynamical mechanism that says why
it had to be exactly that way and was
only by examining the theory more
carefully realized well like it or not
somewhere else in the universe inflation
is still going on and things could look
very different from place to place
that's right and to be fair some or one
of the pioneers of the inflationary
theory if you were sitting at this table
would say you guys are nuts yeah you
would say I now disavow this approach to
cosmology because it gives rise to this
possibility of other universes that's a
possibility that I don't consider still
to be within the realm of scientific
investigation we can say that it's Paul
Steinhardt I want to get him as a future
podcast guys I want to get that
perspective yes and and Paul and I as as
course Paul has had these conversations
with many people but I've had a running
conversation in email debate if you will
with him over the course of many many
years where the emails became so densely
threaded with the back and force that we
had to color code it to know who said
what when and I I see his perspective I
don't agree with his perspective as
fully as he proposes it I think that we
have to be very careful about theories
that propose other universes we have to
recognize that we need a larger
mathematical architecture that can
really allow us to make predictions
within that kind of larger cosmological
framework and I don't think that we have
that on the table right yet I think it
needs to be further developed I feel
that it can be developed Paul thinks
that it is so far beyond where we
currently stand that that may be wishful
thinking and until it's developed we
should not propose this as a bonafide
cosmology I think that's really where
the difference is yeah I think that's
fair and I think that there's sort of
different levels of ambition here right
I mean one is I think what we would all
the highest level is we would like to
make predictions we would like to say
well this is what you should expect
under this ensemble but there's a weaker
level which I think a lot of string
theorists are happy with right now which
is to say if nothing else this picture
of inflation and the string theory
landscape makes it possible that
somewhere there will be conditions where
we could live so the fact that we live
in one of them shouldn't be that
surprising and that like it or not
that's the anthropic principle right
yeah and in fact a version of that
underlies the gold standard of physics
which is the standard model of particle
physics right we we always put forward
the standard model of particle physics
as a grand chief
meant of the 20th century in which we
could describe the interactions of
electrons and quarks and all particles
of that sort and may explain data from
the Large Hadron Collider but of course
the standard model of particle physics
itself is one of an infinite collection
of theories that differ by slight
variations in numbers constants that are
within the equations and how do we
figure out those number linked to the
mass of the electron and Sophia the mass
the electron the strength of the
electromagnetic force the strength of
the nuclear forces and we have no idea
what is the explanation for those
numbers we take it from experimental
observation so we look out at the world
we make measurements we tune our theory
in order that it can explain those
measurements and then we go further to
make new predictions that are about
things that we haven't yet measured and
from that perspective maybe string
theory should be viewed as one of a
large collection of descriptions of
worlds and what we do is we figure out
what the right version of that theory is
through observation and experiment and
then that way when you it down to a
single description or hand flow
descriptions compatible the observation
and therefore having a great many
possible universes coming out of the
mathematics maybe it's not all that
unfamiliar because that's exactly what
happens with the standard model of
particle physics yeah but okay I should
mention that even before we discovered
the cosmological constant and the string
theory landscape different uses of the
word discover in that sentence but we
were talking about the cosmological
constant problem and Steven Weinberg
talked about this possibility of a
multiverse Steven Weinberg one of the
leading physicists of the 20th century
and so he tried to make an argument that
if there were a multiverse with
different values of the vacuum energy
from place-to-place
we should expect to see a small but
nonzero value in our universe did you
buy that at the time do you buy it now
well I buy it as an interesting piece of
data where under a certain set of
assumptions you're naturally led to
imagine that the universe would have a
nonzero cosmological cause
whose value actually turns out to be on
par with observation I think that's an
interesting sentence to be able to utter
that at the same time many he did it
before we saw it and he did before we
saw it so so he's an incredible
insightful physicist the grand master of
physics still with us you know and and
and utterly an amazing job in figuring
this this way of thinking about the
world that at the same time many have
criticized that as the the assumptions
that were made that certain other
qualities of the world
would be fixed and unchanging and only
allowing the cosmological constant to be
the the sole parameter that you dial um
that turns out to be a very limited
framework and if you relax it then the
prediction of the value of the
cosmological constant is also relaxed
and need not be on par with the vibe
that's been observed so it's all just to
say put in the details aside that yes
under certain limited set of assumptions
you can make statements as Weinberg did
before the observations were made that
are on par with what ultimately was
found post facto the belief that you
have that that truly is an argument
supporting the prediction is perhaps
somewhat weaker then all right then
Weinberg himself might have articulated
at the time and so I think that this is
getting us in the right direction in the
sense that if you believe that there
could very plausibly be this multiverse
with different parts of the landscape
being realized in the ensemble then
certainly from that assumptions you can
say okay somewhere there'll be a world
in which we can live but making
predictions involves other issues like
how much volume of space are occupied by
these different possibilities how many
stars form in all of them how many
observers form in all of them you know
do we know what an observer is do we
know what life is have we made progress
on these questions yes I'd say there's
been a very small amount of progress
relative to the towering difficulty of
the problems that you articulated so
it's not like we're stuck but I would
say that we're nowhere near being able
to say oh just a few more details and
we'll have finished this off and
be able to make these kinds of
probabilistic statistical statements
about physics in a in a universe that or
in a vast cosmology that has all these
universes within it
so yes progress no nowhere near the
answer and that's the heart of the worry
of someone like Steinhardt which is he
thinks that there isn't an answer like
there's an infinite number of everything
you can't say there's more of one thing
than another you can't make any
predictions whatsoever is that right
yeah that that's that is at the heart of
it and my own feeling of course I think
many in the field I've interested to
hear your view is that it doesn't seem
as insuperable to me yeah it seems to me
difficult it seems to me vitally
important to make these theories
scientifically sound but I don't see
that there is some insurmountable hurdle
that's facing us I mean we're pretty
clever we're pretty smart as a community
and I think that we will be able to make
headway on this ya know I think that's
more or less exactly my view I mean
certainly I don't think that we should
now give up on the possibility of coming
up with some principle or some
understanding let's accept the problem
is a good one absolutely and therefore
try to solve it not just declare defeat
for my shirt right right but okay
other people worry and I think I know
the answer to this myself that let's
hear it in your voice
other people worried that this is sort
of just putting human beings back at the
center of the universe in some sense to
say that rather than being scientists
making predictions and saying what
things should be using these anthropic
or environmental selection arguments
makes things a little bit too anti
Copernican to human centered is that
something we should worry about is it
kind of a cop-out no I don't I don't see
it that way at all I mean it's an
observational fact that we're here and
therefore any successful theory should
be compatible with that observation it's
one of many observations of the world
that a theory needs to be compatible
with and you use those observations that
are most potent at winning down the
spectrum of possibility so the fact that
we are going to in
impose on this collection of universes
that the conditions need to allow us to
be here to make statements that is just
pure logic it has nothing to do with
putting us back in the center of things
and again it's not the only condition
that we put on things it's one of a
grand collection and it may be a potent
one in order to make a first step in
slicing down the range of possibility so
I don't find that a concern at all I
like to say that you know we're not
surprised that life grew up on the
biosphere the atmosphere of the earth
even though there's a lot more space in
between the planets like there's clearly
a selection effect here and that's okay
yeah the fact that we're here and not on
Pluto yeah
that that's understandable by virtue of
the conditions here versus those bumpy
it's not even a planet you know I've
heard that yeah that'll be enough okay
but on the other hand on the slightly
more pessimistic side you know this idea
of eternally inflating cosmos going on
forever a large maybe infinite number of
local conditions in different parts of
it does lead us to some bizarre thing
Yeah right like my favorite bizarre
thing is the Boltzmann brain yeah it was
your what can you explain that problem
to us and that give us your feelings
good yeah you know if you if you ask
yourself in the far future if they're
just particles drifting around in the
void could a random fluctuation of the
positions of those particles somehow
come together to randomly yield
structure and there's a nonzero chance
that that could happen enough time in
enough space these kinds of very
unlikely coming together to particles
are bound to happen
and indeed the structures could be
things that are familiar to us in fact
it could be a human brain just randomly
forming out in the void from particles
that are floating around in the darkness
and that human brain could have within
it in memories impressed by virtue of
the particle configurations I mean right
now as I look out in the world I
remember a past when I was a kid growing
up and learning quantum mechanically
quantity Riemann I think I remember
exactly the that's exactly the point
because right now all those memories are
just configurations of particles right
here right now so if we were to recreate
that configuration of particles it would
have the same memories and sensations
and therefore think that had a history
that never existed so it's possible that
brains could form out there in the void
spontaneously the problem with that and
the reason why people like to ensure
that the theory gets rid of this as a
prediction is that the reason we believe
in the equations is because we believe
that we encounter data supporting the
predictions of those equations but if we
can't trust any of our memories we can't
trust our memories of seeing data that
supported the very theories that lead us
to the possibility that there's a brain
floating in the void so we come into a
kind of skeptical nightmare where we
undercut the very rationality of thought
so the goal of many theories is to find
some way of not only explaining
everything that we see in the world
around us explaining that the conditions
allow for human life to exist but also
somehow avoiding the possibility that
the distant future these brains will
form in the void and if you can do that
we feel that the theory has a better
chance of being correct because it
doesn't suffer from this logical
skeptical nightmare that can emerge in
theories that allow these Boltzmann
brains to form so should we be worried
about the multiverse is it generically
true that in these stories of eternal
inflation in the landscape there are
more Boltzmann brains in some sense than
ordinary observers or do we not know
well it depends again in some sense at
the level of explanation that you're
shooting for so if you're happy to say
that yes these brains may be out there
in other realms but we're going to limit
our explanation of our observations to
the small part of the multiverse and
within that we can tell a
self-consistent story and and maybe an
our universe within the multiverse
perhaps the universe ends before there's
time for these Boltzmann brains to form
then much like the standard model is one
of many theories that explains
observations this would be one of many
universes that explains our observations
without running into the skeptical
nightmare of Boltzmann brains however if
you're looking for the full explanation
of reality then that isn't good enough
and the full explanation of reality do
face a quandary which is if I say to you
where did your brain come from the
natural answer if you believe in this
both in brain scenarios well it just
formed right now and the void and all
these memories that I have are nonsense
or things that never took place and
that's an uncomfortable state of affairs
and you definitely want to have some way
of reporting that criticism of your
theory and people have come up with
various ideas trying to make it that the
regions in which these Boulton brains
forms somehow have a very
extraordinarily low probability so yes
it's possible but compared to the
reality that we're familiar with it's
just so unlikely that somehow we can
push it to the side but in the universe
that or our multiverse of last forever
and perhaps goes on forever it's sort of
hard to make those cuts right so this is
it is an issue that needs to be
addressed yeah but isn't it also
possible that just at the technical
level of mathematics that were being a
little bit too glib about these 10 to
the 500 different compactification of
string theory you know is it possible
that maybe they're just temporary maybe
they all dissolve away can we hope to
maybe recover some more unique
prediction for what the universe should
look like yeah in fact you know people
have written along as I and I had one
paper a couple years ago which tried to
argue that there is an instability in
the landscape that most of these other
universes would pretty quickly
disintegrate and if that were the case
then you wouldn't have to deal with them
on an equal footing because they might
be here for a brief moment but then
they're gone yeah there's some criticism
of that paper and then you know it goes
on yeah so but it's just to say that yes
we may be too quickly accepting the
possibility of all these other realms
and maybe deeper analysis which people
are now starting to undertake in earnest
might find that yes they are allowed by
the most
a superficial analysis of the equations
but a deeper analysis allows us to get
around them in some way either that
they're not really there or they're
unstable or somehow our realm rises up
with such a fantastically large
probability that the others can somehow
be ignored so all of these are on the
table in order to avoid this problem of
a theory that undercuts its own
rationality does it seem strange to you
that in all of these stories of eternal
inflation the past of the universe seems
so dramatically different than the
future it does and it's a question of no
that has troubled you and we've had
conversations of this about this over
the years you know when you're dealing
with in theory whose equations seem to
make no distinction between what you
call forward in time what we call
backward in time and yet you look at a
reality that has such a radical
difference between what we humans call
forward in time and what we humans call
backward in time that mismatch makes you
scratch your head and we have been
scratching it and there are solutions on
the table I know that you've put forward
a number of ideas along those lines I
have to now and then not as many or as
effective as yours perhaps but it is an
issue that at the moment we pretty much
solved by Fiat right we say that the Big
Bang conditions were highly ordered we
don't know why we don't know how it came
to be but if we posit that then there's
a natural asymmetry that emerges not
from the equations but from the
conditions and the conditions of low
entropy high order naturally unfold to a
future that has lower order higher
entropy and that yields us a distinction
between forward and backward but we
really put it in by hand it's not
something that emerges from some
fundamental principle there very
recently has been some people you
alluded to this earlier but so now I
guess it's time to dig into it there's
been a recent set of claims that say you
know back in 1998 when we talked about
this kitchen sink construction that gave
us a positive vacuum energy maybe we
were too hasty maybe a little bit too
glib there and you know we could poke
holes in that and maybe maybe the reason
why
none of these constructions are
perfectly convincing is because in fact
string theory just doesn't let you have
a positive cosmological constant can you
tell us about this idea yeah so when we
do analysis in string theory we
generally do it with an approximation
scheme we don't often have the capacity
to analyze the equations with full
precision so we ignore certain parts of
the equations and try to argue that what
we ignore it doesn't change our
conclusions in any deeper important way
it may qualitatively affect them
somewhat but we think the general
conclusion would still hold and that was
certainly the approach that was taken in
in KK L T this famous paper that
introduced a way of getting the positive
vacuum energy people now have revisited
those approximation schemes and called
them into question now as far as I know
the authors of the paper fully stand by
they have made they have not that I do
my impression yeah whereas there are
others in the community or at least
calling attention to the possibility
that we may have all bought in a little
too quickly to the approximation scheme
that gave rise to those solutions and
we're that to be the case it would be
fantastically interesting obviously we
call into question over a decade maybe
close to two decades of research which
again that's how it goes that that
that's why science is beautiful it's
self-correcting there's no error that
will stand the test of time because
people always go back and always think
through and always take a sledgehammer
to try to smash results of the past this
is a result that people thought would be
impervious to that kind of a
sledgehammer attack and who knows maybe
it is but it's good it's healthy that
it's back on the table and people are
examining it as a as a possible thing
that we bought into too quickly but what
do we say if on the one hand you say
string theory does not have any
solutions possibly with a positive
vacuum energy but the astronomers have
observed a positive acumen energy good
that is that is a natural question and
it could well be that this positive
vacuum energy might not be constant so
we've observed it over a relatively
short period of time so we
know that the accelerator expansion
began I don't know seven eight billion
years ago and yeah perhaps it's still
going on a short period of time we don't
mean twenty years we mean a couple
billion a couple billion years but you
know the future will have many more
billions of years than the billions that
we have so far had access to in
principle the universe could go on for
for trillions and and and maybe even
infinitely long we don't know and in
that scenario in the very far future
perhaps it's the case that the vacuum
energy slowly decays maybe gets smaller
and smaller
maybe in the very far future it will be
gone and those kinds of solutions with a
steadily decaying vacuum energy are
somewhat easier to accommodate within
our theories so it could be the case
that what we're learning is that the
particular version of positive vacuum
energy that we thought was compatible
with observations and with the
mathematics of string theory maybe
that's naive version is not the one that
the universe makes use of nor which the
equations of string theory can
accommodate maybe it's this more subtle
version where the energy kind of decays
or changes over time
maybe that's both compatible to
observations and with a more refined
mathematical analysis in string theory
and are you saying that this is an
experimental II testable prediction of
string theory yeah it's sort of
interesting how the critics of string
theory say completely divorced from
observation or experiment and yet here
we've had a bulk of our conversation
driven by an observation that took place
in 1998 and observation the won the
Nobel Prizes significant observation so
it kind of tells the lie of string
theorists ignoring or having nothing to
do with observation experiment but I
would say it's too quick to say that
this is a prediction of string theory we
need to understand the mathematics
better and we need to go back to the
papers of the 9th late 1990s and
determine whether or not we agree with
that analysis whether that analysis
needs to be changed and if it does need
to be changed yes it could be the case
that we come out with a prediction that
the dark energy the energy of empty
space should change over time right that
could be an interesting prediction if
indeed this is the
a the analysis unfolds and it is a major
program of observational cosmology to
test whether this is the case absolutely
we're now having millions of dollars
we're spending a lot of money to do this
and the other thing to bear in mind is
it could be that those results are
inconclusive
I could appear that the dark energy is
constant at the level of accuracy that
we're able to muster with the technology
that we have at our disposal it could
still be changing yeah and and and
that's again the way science progresses
so it could be that it requires a
hundred or 500 years in the future
before we're able to actually come up
with a definitive observational
statement about how the dark energy
changes in time but maybe we'll get
lucky maybe the change is sufficiently
large that we'll be able to detect it
and that again will be one of these
inflection points in our analysis of
string theory okay to sort of wrap
things up a couple of more big-picture
questions here we've turned on the Large
Hadron Collider a while ago we found the
Higgs boson Nobel Prizes were handed out
everyone's very happy and tears were
shed tears yes exactly it tears of joy
you know relief although tears could
also been chipped by the folks who
didn't get the Nobel Prize but were
associates let's leave that ears all
over it all of it but also tears because
we haven't found anything else yeah yeah
and there certainly is at least an
association of string theory with this
idea of supersymmetry yes a hypothetical
theory symmetry of nature that could
have been discovered at the LHC in fact
maybe next year it will be but it hasn't
been yet what is your feeling of what
we've learned from that lack of
discovery well I certainly frequently
when I would speak about these ideas in
public settings would point to
supersymmetry as the most likely way
that we would have experimental insight
into what the string theory is right or
wrong and I think many of us hoped that
the Large Hadron Collider would turn up
the collection of particles that
supersymmetry requires that have never
been observed in fact when I do a survey
of my own papers just a sort of one data
point since I was a graduate student
back in the 80s as
significant fraction of them rely on the
idea of supersymmetry so finding it
would have been very very exciting for a
lot of people who's worked for decades
assumed that it was true now the fact
that we've not seen it is not in any way
proof that string theory is wrong and
they don't see that joyfully right if it
was proof going back to how we began if
it was proof that string theory is wrong
I would be thrilled because then it
would be time to let the theory go and
to move on to other things we want to
know the answer
exactly and and that's not facetious
that's really straight on how we look at
physics as a an approach to
understanding reality but the fact that
it has not yet been discovered and the
fact that it may not be discovered in
the coming year or so at the Large
Hadron Collider could all amount to the
statement that we need a more powerful
machine to reveal it that certainly is
compatible with our understanding of the
mathematics so what I would say is it is
a it is an interesting data point
suggesting that the most straightforward
version of the theory is perhaps not in
agreement with observations but it
doesn't in any way give us full insight
into whether theory is right or wrong
that there is fully compatible with
anything that will emerge from the Large
Hadron Collider over the next year or
two but it is worrisome even putting
aside specific questions about string
theory and supersymmetry that we haven't
seen anything else this is shocking from
a very general sort of particle physics
perspective right yes absolutely there
is there's general arguments that our
understanding from the equations of the
standard model needed something else to
emerge at roughly the scale at which the
Large Hadron Collider is able to probe
the world
now that really came in some sense from
an aesthetic mathematical sensibility we
like our theories to not be highly tuned
we like our theories to be robust
against small changes in parameters and
that's really what led us to this
generic notion that there needed to be
something else but the standard model
all by itself
without anything else could indeed
explain the observations I think many of
us would find that hard to stomach from
a mathematical standpoint but the
universe is not in the business of
pleasing our mathematical tastes so it
could be that that just is how the world
works and that there isn't anything else
to be found until much much much higher
scales where ideas of quantum gravity
will will make an appearance so I think
we need to be very careful in imposing
human mathematical sensibility and human
aesthetic sensibility on how the world
works yeah and as far as we know there's
no kind of multiverse solution to that
problem in the same way that there is
for the vacuum energy that's correct yes
okay and okay good then the final
question is sort of a State of the Union
address kind of question string theory
has been around a long time I mean that
the modern version of string theory more
or less coincides with your career as a
physicist right I don't know what the
causality is there but roughly speaking
the timing works out yes and it's
changed there been revolutions in string
theory and I think you know the
impression I get from talking to string
theorists and I think from the podcast
with Clifford there's been an enormous
amount of recent effort in applying
ideas from string theory to this and
that completely different physics
problems in nuclear physics or atomic
physics or fluid dynamics or whatever
what is your feeling about the prospects
for string Theory's original hope of
being a theory of everything being a
quantum theory of gravity well I I'm
still quite optimistic about its utility
in answering those specific questions
you know the unified theory of gravity
quantum mechanics perhaps explaining the
particle properties and so forth what I
think is completely unclear is the time
scale over which we're going to learn
whether it is that theory and if it is
that theory the time scale over which
we'll be able to extract those qualities
by virtue of having a sufficiently
robust mathematical understanding of a
very complex structure so my own sense
is that there's a possibility that in
the not-too-distant future string theory
might migrate out of physics departments
into mathematics departments where it
will be pursued as an interesting piece
of
automatical architecture that cries out
for deeper understanding and deeper
analysis but there may be a phase during
which its connection to physics is
relatively modest or non-existent
because it's hard for a theory of
physics to flourish without contact with
observation and experiment now we saw
again just to go back to our
conversation there can be unexpected
links between observation and and theory
the observation of the distant motion of
galaxies wouldn't it first sight be the
place you'd look for some evidence or
observations relevant to a theory that's
talking about the smallest things in the
world right right that seems to be the
biggest gulf imaginable and yet through
our conversation we've gone through the
history of how there is a link between
the two which is exciting so we would
need to have our eyes open and not think
that the strength ear is now sequestered
into a more mathematical part of the
academic world but that may be where its
development sits for some period of time
aren't you cross appointed in physics
and math here at Columbia yes I I hitch
might be out saying that I'm safe but in
some sense I mean was it too much to ask
back in the 80s that you know we were
gonna use string theory to get the
theory of everything and calculate the
mass of the electron and things like
that well too much ask is an interesting
sociological question and I was there at
the time and I can tell you that the
notion that we were on the verge of
explaining it all didn't come from some
PR strategy it was coming from a genuine
excitement about about where we might be
so I don't think you can criticize
people for being excited about things
even though probably it was somewhat
over exuberant but it came from a good
place it came from a genuine desire to
understand the world and I think that is
something that we should we should
celebrate and respect and recognize that
it's tapping into a human enthusiasm in
the human urge for understanding and
from that perspective it was
pure here at the mindscape podcast we do
not criticize people for being excited
they're like good so glad to hear it
Brian Greene thanks so much for
appearing on the podcast my pleasure
[Music]
you
[Music]